Great. Well, thanks everyone for joining us for this session.
It's late in the day and late in the
ACR meeting. It's my great pleasure to talk to you
in this Meet the Experts session. We'll try and make it
relatively informal since we have a small audience and have plenty of
time for Q&A.
So I'm going to talk about work that we and others have done in
helping to apply the molecular classifications of
lymphomas, particularly with a focus on diffuse large B-cell lymphoma and how
that can translate into therapy and into clinical trials.
And these are my disclosures. They relate predominantly to my work as a consultant
in the design of clinical trials for patients with lymphomas,
work with Natera and Empower Medicine,
and then also research funding for my role as the division head for the
Division of Cancer Medicine, where I oversee all of medical oncology.
So when we think about the incidence of lymphoid malignancies
in the United States, these are data that we developed in collaboration
with the American Cancer Society, and actually in this
lecture room yesterday at about exactly this same
time. Ahmedin Jamal, who's the second to last author
here, was in this room giving his presentation for the Jane
Cook Wright Award. And this really was the first effort that
was made using data from across the United States to perform
classification by the World Health Organization classification for
all lymphoid malignancies, where you can see that diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma, shown down here in the bottom blue
triangle portion of the pie chart, makes up about a
quarter of all patients with lymphoid malignancies.
And you can see that's actually more than what's listed here as
PCN or plasma cell neoplasms. That represents all of myeloma.
So this one subtype of lymphomas is more than all of multiple
myeloma. These are data from the
2016 facts and figures, but now that has been moved
forward, and now we see about close to 30,000 patients with diffuse
large B-cell lymphoma in the United States.
The other thing that we described that there are differences by
populations in terms of what the expected two-year or five-year and
10-year overall survival, and that's also been a mission of our work, is to be able
to understand why those differences occur and how you can overcome
those differences in outcome.
And so when we think about the therapy of diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, this is a
standard survival curve that dates back a little bit more than a
decade, but based on therapy that really stood the
test of time, where you can see this top red curve represents
the combination of rituximab and CHOP therapy compared to
CHOP chemotherapy alone. In a little bit more than a decade, we
finally had the long-term survival of that, showing a separation of these curves
that persisted and also was associated with an overall
survival difference. But I think when you look at the shape of these curves, that
shape of these curves has not really changed over time in that
there's a steep drop-off in the first two years, both in terms of
progression-free survival and overall survival for patients to
suggest that we need to do other things to be able to
modify rituximab and CHOP therapy to be able to
predict the quality of response or to take into consideration
biological diversity of the disease to be able to improve outcomes for
patients, particularly in this era.
And I'll go through a decade's worth of work to try and do
that.
And so we've known for now more than two
decades in work that was led by Ash
Alizadeh when he was first at the NCI and then at
Stanford, that described that there are molecular subtypes of diffuse large
B-cell lymphoma, the two major ones being classified by gene expression
profiling,
the germinal center B-cell-like, and the activated
B-cell-like diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
Those can be identified through other approaches by
gene expression profiling and then translate into differences in outcome, where you
can see that patients shown here in yellow with
GCB diffuse large B-cell lymphoma have improved progression-free
survival and overall survival, and that patient population
with
activated B-cell-like diffuse large B-cell lymphoma has worse outcomes.
And that's been translated clinically into the use of
immunohistochemistry, with the Hans algorithm being the most commonly used
algorithm across the United States and the world.
But this algorithm fails to
define the exact gene expression profile to find
subtypes and calls the group
non-GCB that is classified using the Hans
algorithm here because it has about 20%
misclassification of lymphomas in the modern era
when that's used. And I'll return to that throughout the talk about how
we are currently classifying lymphomas really does not translate into ways
that we can make actionable clinically at this point.
And what we've seen over a series of years
after that first trial that I showed you of R-CHOP versus CHOP were
a few other trials that also showed that adding rituximab to
therapy provided benefits. But then with a series of trials after
that, there were a number of modifications with a focus on being able to
address that molecular classification, predominantly using the Hans algorithm,
that really were ultimately negative trials, with the only positive one of
those trials being a trial that was a Phase
II clinical trial and then had a confirmatory Phase III trial that turned out
to be a negative trial. And so while we
were able to molecularly classify diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, we struggled with
translating that into clinical applications that were
useful.One of the things that we were able to do with these data and others,
though, was actually leverage them to be able to redefine the surrogate
endpoints for diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
And this is work that I did with Tian Xu who
is a
biostatistician from Mayo Clinic, and investigators from
across the world to be able to define a new surrogate endpoint
for overall survival in diffuse large B-cell lymphoma progression,
free survival, and that ultimately was used in a series of clinical
trials that you'll see going forward.
And I think this proves as an important point for the ways that
we need to advance the field as we're moving molecular
classifications with newer technologies like detection of minimum
residual disease and others,
that we now need to go back and recreate new endpoints,
because even with progression-free survival we would likely expect that it
will take seven to 10 years for a new drug to reach that
endpoint, which is unacceptably long for patients to
wait for new therapies for the frontline for diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
But while this therapy was available, or while this endpoint
was available, we ultimately were able to use that
for the development and validation of a
new therapy for patients with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma and some of
the folks in the room with me were key players in
that. I was the US lead for this clinical trial.
That was a worldwide clinical trial that involved the new
anti-CD79B antibody drug conjugate
polatuzumab in combination with an R-CHOP regimen where
the vincristine was dropped and then replaced by a vincristine
placebo versus standard R-CHOP. And then two
additional cycles of rituximab were given because in Europe, more commonly, they
gave eight cycles of therapy than six cycles as we do in the United States.
And this was for patients stratified by International
Prognostic Index who had a higher IPI score.
And as you can see here, progression-free survival, that endpoint
that we developed through surrogacy was used as the endpoint for this trial.
And ultimately what that trial showed was an improvement in progression-free
survival for the arm shown here in green that received polo R-CHIP
compared to patients who received R-CHOP with a hazard ratio of
0.73, and I'll have you
remember and focus on that hazard ratio.
But that provides a meaningful benefit for patients with
diffuse large B-cell lymphoma when selected by International
Prognostic Index
for patients overall.
And what we've seen more recently in a follow-up to this trial that was published
at the tail end of last year in "The Journal of Clinical Oncology" is that
progression free survival benefit was maintained with the polo R-CHIP
shown here in green again maintaining a very similar
survival benefit and confirmed that hazard ratio of 0.73 that
was seen at the initial
evaluation. And so as we look towards the
future, the question is what is really next for patients with diffuse large
B-cell lymphoma with that now established as a new
additional standard of care for patients?
And I think the next thing that we really are hoping for is the development
of subtype differentiated therapy which has remained a
challenge for patients. We do know in secondary analyses
of the POLARIX trial shown here from data that
were first presented by Franck Morschhäuser in our group at the
ASH meetings shown in terms of progression-free survivals and then
eventually also published as hazard
ratios and forest plots in that JCO publication that
the predominant benefit for patients with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma when
stratified by genotype is in the group that had the
ABC subtype where you can see dramatic differences for the group that
received polo R-CHIP now shown in the blue compared to those patients
who received R-CHOP. But I think the other thing to
note is that there are a multitude of factors that influence outcomes, not just
genotype. And the other thing that is critical is that this genotype is
defined by gene expression profiling, not defined by
immunohistochemistry algorithms.
And when we've tried to do that by immunohistochemistry algorithms, we've not seen
differences in frontline therapy for patients, at least
in real-world studies that have done that.
And so in my mind, if you want to use these data to inform therapy,
and I'll show you some strategies potentially for doing that, it really needs to be
based on gene expression profiling as the way that you define that.
And so
in the interim, there have been a number of things that have come up beyond just
gene expression profiling to be able to define subtypes.
There have been a series of four major papers that used whole exome
sequencing and RNA sequencing to be able to sub-stratify
diffuse large B-cell lymphoma
including work that was done by Sandip
Dave in this first paper in "Cell," group that was led
by Margaret Shipp's group and work by Lou
Staudt's group that further stratified the ABC and GCB
subgroups into further subgroups and additional work that was done
by the group at British Columbia.
And I think
beyond that, we've also seen by gene expression profiling that you can further
sub-stratify diffuse large B-cell lymphoma using an approach
for gene expression what's now called the dark zone signature
or DZ-Sig, was originally called the double hit signature as a show or
DHIT-Sig, where you can see here in the red
survival curves that beyond the ABC subtype shown in
blue and the GCB subtype shown in
yellow that a subgroup of the GCB subtype that has this dark
zone signature has markedly worse outcomes with diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma. And I think importantly in routine clinical
classification, we identify these patients by FISH
subtype but what this paper also showed is that if you look
that approximately 62% of those patients
who fall into this dark zone signature group do not have double hit by
FISH. And so there are yet more patients that we can pick up that have poor
outcomes with R-CHOP and likely should be getting treated a little bit
differently.I think the other thing that is just
new and hot off the presses and came out earlier this week is a follow-up
to this work that was led by Laura Hilton, who's
a collaborator of ours from British Columbia, who showed that
if you look using the newer
classification system in terms of the molecular classifiers
for the group that had EZB, ST2,
BN2, N1, MCD, and A53
using the LymphGen classification, and then add on that dark zone
signature or those dark zone signature positives, the other way this group
is called is the EZB MYC positive group.
There was really only those dark zone signature positive patients that had
differences in outcome with R-CHOP.
This paper actually used the exact same data
set or 314 of the patients that came from this population-based
data set, and really is one of the first studies to actually use
population-based data to look at the molecular stratifiers.
And unlike what I call convenient samples that come from pathologists'
stores of tissues, where we have seen differences in outcomes
for both the DLBCL class and for LymphGen,
when you use population-based data, we do not see differences outcome
in this setting. We actually also have a
group of about 450 patients that we've sequenced across eight academic medical
centers that I'll allude to in a little bit that shows something very
similar that we have unpublished data on as well.
And so I think this is something that will help us to think about the ways
that we use molecular classifiers in the future.
The other thing that we're thinking about here is how do we ultimately get this to
patients? And I think, as I mentioned, it's been a real challenge
to use immunohistochemistry because of the misclassification that we
see with the Hans algorithm. There also have been additional approaches using
immunohistochemistry to be able to define the group that has dark zone signature
that also has real problems with misclassification.
And so we've made approaches to be able to bring that directly to patients
by using whole exome sequencing and an RNA-seq-based approach that
can give you the classifiers using things like the LymphGen
classification. Additionally, give you things like the double hit or dark
zone signature classification, gene expression-based cell of origin
classifiers, as well as additional data on the lymphoma
microenvironment by gene expression profiling.
And what we've seen when we apply that to patients
more directly, and this is a study that was presented at the ASH
meeting in 2024 and is under review right now,
both for duly diagnosed patients and relapsed refractory patients, I think the
first major finding is that we were able to do this testing with a turnaround
time, a median of about 10 days for patients.
And so you can actually get these back in real time to be able to make
decisions for patients. And this also recapitulates the same things that we've
seen in terms of cell of origin that can be defined, dark
zone signature that you can identify, classifiers of the lymphoma
microenvironment, as well as LymphGen.
And we've also shown in other data that are not part of this publication that you
can generate DLBCL class data, both for newly
diagnosed and relapsed patients with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma or
large B-cell lymphoma.
And that there are relationships between different methods of using
this classification system. And there are methods that were developed
first back in 2021 by the group at Boster Gene, as well as
newer methods that have used data from a
Genentech trial to be able to create a cell of origin
classification that completely matches the
NanoString approach for being able to do this, as well as creating a
new dark zone signature classifier that could be used in clinical trials
similar to what the data that I showed you from Laura Hilton.
And so really our next phases of doing this are now taking this to patients
in real-world studies. This is a protocol that is led by Dai
Chihara from our group, who's been a key leader in this work, is
already moving forward, and we are actually going to run in
community-based practices both in the state of Texas
and in the state of Georgia. We're using that same
assay. We'll generate gene expression-based cell of origin, dark zone
signature, as well as additional data on LymphGen and DLBCL
class. I'll show you some of the LymphoMAP data in a
little bit, as well as in a different
lymphoma microenvironment classifier.
And using those data sets ultimately help clinicians
with the process of treatment decision-making with suggestions that patients
who get ABC or have unclassified
gene expression profiling go on to receive Polar Chip based on the data that I
showed you. Based on other data that patients who fall
into that dark zone signature group get dose-adjusted
or EPOCH as a more intensified therapy that we've seen is better
for patients with double-hit diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, and
patients who have standard GCB and are dark zone
signature get standard R-CHOP as their therapy.
And so we're now moving that forward.
The province of British Columbia is actually also moving a similar
study forward for all patients who receive care
in their province.
And one of the ways that we've been able to do this is by some of our work in team
science, and this has been really a joy of my career to be
able to work with a number of investigators.
Gene Coff and I lead this work, and a
component of our work as part of project two is this
trial that Dai Chihara is doing in terms of translating genomics
into clinical practice. In addition to this, in work that I won't talk about,
we're developing specific targets or specific ways
of using digital pathology to be able to get tools out to community-based
practices for making these using just a simple H&E slide.
I won't talk about any of that, and I'll talk a little bit about some of our
partition targeting work that will happen as part of project
one.But one of the things that's also been a benefit of this
collaboration is the group that I mentioned, as well as collaborations that we've
had with Blood Cancer United through impact-funded grant,
where Chijioke Nze from our site runs a series
of
related studies that go through community-based
practices in parts of rural Texas, as well as parts
of Louisiana and our partnership with Oschner.
And Jonathan Cohen, my mentee from the time when I was at
Emory, runs a series of trials
through the Georgia Research Alliance through community-based practices
there. There also are similar impact grants from Cornell that
are funded and led by LEO
investigators that I'll get to in a moment, as well as from the Mayo Clinic
and other Blood Cancer United grants that are led at
University of Colorado and City of Hope that are also led by lymphoma
investigators. And so I think this creates a really nice opportunity for us to
be able to leverage this, to be able to get the kinds of clinical trials that are
innovative out to community-based practices much more rapidly.
And so what's next in the field for diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma? I think the next thing is additional first-line options, and I kind of
alluded to this a little bit at the beginning of my talk with that hazard
ratio that I showed you. One of the things that we've known that's been a
particular problem for trials with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma and the management
of patients with lymphoma in general, is work that was led by Matt Maurer, who's a
biostatistician at the Mayo Clinic and collaborates closely with
us, where here you see the distribution of the diagnosis to treatment
interval. So the time from when somebody's diagnosed with diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma to when they start treatment.
Shown in blue are the data for the Mayo Clinic and the
Iowa Clinics, and shown in yellow are
what we see for the LISA group across France.
And you can see that
perhaps somewhat paradoxically, if you look at patients by
diagnosis to treatment interval, those patients who have the shortest diagnosis to
treatment interval, zero to six days or seven to 13
days, are the patients who have the worst outcome.
We usually think about cancer as a disease that if you make a diagnosis
sooner, that you're likely to do better.
But I think all of us who treat lymphomas know that when you need to start
treatment immediately after diagnosis, that's generally a patient
who has a bad disease, and that's exactly what this shows.
The other thing through work that Matt has done has
shown that if you look at the median time
of diagnosis to treatment interval on all those trials that I showed you that
failed, the median time to diagnosis treatment interval is about 30
days. So the kinds of patients we're putting on clinical trials
are these patients up here at the top of the survival curve.
And understandably, when you try and make an intervention on the patients who are
likely to do best with standard of care, it's less likely that your new
intervention is going to work. And so we really need to think about how do we get
patients like this onto clinical trials sooner and faster,
and with approaches like what we're doing to use molecular testing that comes
back quickly and allows the decisions to be made.
And so the other thing that's been a problem in lymphoma clinical trials is this
issue that was described is that when you look over time from when
I started doing research in this field to a little bit
in the more recent future, the number of eligibility criteria that
patients use or needed to meet to go on to clinical trials
are becoming much, much more restrictive.
And that's also limiting our ability to get those patients on quickly.
So one of the things that we've been able to do through our Lymphoma Epidemiology
of Outcomes Consortium is to be able to leverage data
across eight academic medical centers where we have collaborators at
each of these groups that are leaders in the field of lymphoma,
including the leaders of all the cooperative groups, Jonathan Friedberg, who's the
SWOG Lymphoma Chair, John Leonard, who's the Alliance Chair, who
recently moved from Cornell to NYU, and Brad Call,
who's the ECOG Lymphoma Chair, to be able to integrate standard of care data
from all of these institutions and to be able to leverage that to help us to make
better decisions about what we do moving forward.
And so across this group, if you look at the first five years of our
accrual
from 2015 to 2020, we accrued more than
7,700 patients across these eight academic medical centers.
And I think the thing importantly is that if you look at the data for the patients
that we accrued, that our data across our medical centers looks
very similar to the SEER data or the US data for
lymphomas, with very similar distributions of men and women,
distributions by age of lymphoma, with the exception of the oldest old,
where we don't capture them quite as well in LEO as we do in SEER.
But distributions by race, where we see similar numbers of Hispanic
patients and people who self-report as Black or
African American. We underrepresent for Asian and Pacific
Islanders in our population because the vast majority of
our patient population is to the right of the Mississippi.
But we also have a similar distribution of non-Hodgkin lymphoma subtypes.
And so that's really given us the opportunity to be able to leverage these data
to be able to answer questions about clinical trials.
And this is work
from Arushi Kharana that was published two years ago who
is a junior investigator at Mayo Clinic, where she showed if you look across
our LEO data and look at the eligibility criteria for common
Phase III clinical trials, those trials that I showed you earlier,
that the eligibility criteria
impact anywhere from 9% of patients
to make them ineligible for going on clinical trials to up to
37% of patients who are ineligible for going on clinical trials.
And so we really need to do a better job.
The other thing is that for those patient populations that we
most want to be representative of the United States, like
patients who self-report as Hispanic or Black, those patients also,
at least in two of the trials,
were disproportionately
impacted by these eligibility criteria.
And soOne of the things we've also done with our LEO investigators is to
be able to leverage that work to be able to redesign eligibility
criteria for diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
And this is work that was done by Andrew Harkins when he was a medical student at
Emory and working with me. Andrew is actually now joining the faculty
at MD Anderson in a couple of weeks.
And he, with all these LEO investigators, ultimately decided
what were the kinds of criteria that were absolutely essential, shown
here in green, the ones where they were completely unnecessary,
shown in red, or where there was disagreement across the
investigators that we had in the LEO
consortium. And then ultimately went from what is
normally been seen on diffuse large B-cell lymphoma trials of about
37 eligibility criteria for most trials, down to
13 criteria that we said were absolutely essential.
And in the more recent trials, we've actually been able to integrate
those into trials. First, taking the diagnosis to treatment
interval from Matt Maurer to say that we wanted to enroll
patients on trials who have a diagnosis to treatment interval of less than
28 days. And then taking these consensus essential
criteria and making those the eligibility criteria for this trial.
And this was a trial that looked at the combination of tafasitamab and
lenalidomide with R-CHOP in
the experimental arm versus placebo in the control arm.
And
this also used that same endpoint that we validated progression-free survival.
And what you see is that this trial now has been reported out
as being a positive trial. We're waiting for the data.
You can again see that the hazard ratio is around
0.75. Like the other positive trials, there was another
positive trial that was run in China, that was reported out at ASH last
year. And there were a series of other trials that are using progression-free
survival as endpoints that we're hoping to see report out in the
coming years
using
newer combination regimens that hopefully will improve upon the outcomes
that we've seen with polo R-CHIP and with R-CHOP.
And so what's next as these trials start to report
out? We really want to move towards biologically targeted approaches.
And these are data that I alluded to from the work that's part of our first
project in that SPOR grant.
Michelle Lee, who was a medical student who was working with me on this project at
the
time when she was at Emory, now is actually joining the faculty at Emory.
So you can see a trend here with these medical students that work in lymphoma,
ultimately staying in the field. And so Michelle helped us with
original work that helped to use one of those large sequencing
data sets where Emory contributed about 100 of the patients to
one of those larger projects, and 81 of those patients
were patients of African ancestry, determined
by sequencing of the tumor. And you can see that for
specific
driver mutations that were associated with DNA damage repair, like
ATM, MGA, and SETD2, that these were
more commonly represented in people of African ancestry
than people of European ancestry in this
population. We have since gone on to leverage that
data with the development of a SETD2 mouse model in collaboration with Ari
Melnick in that group,
and describe that SETD2 insufficiency is
something that leads to synthetic lethality.
And so when we see SETD2 in mice or in humans,
it's something that occurs in the haploinsufficient state.
And so when you knock out the other allele of SETD2, that actually leads to
killing the tumor.
And so if leverage that in collaboration with
a company to try and help to develop a SETD2 inhibitor.
Unfortunately,
when the company Epizyme was bought, that SETD2 inhibitor has been
shelved. But I'm working with our
technology and licensing group within MD Anderson actually to try and bring that
back and to be able to reinitiate a clinical trial.
And that's actually work that we did here at the ACR
meeting. This is a drug that's made it through the first three steps
of Phase 2. I was actually the US senior investigator
on this trial. We have not seen toxicity with this agent and are
looking to move it forward to complete the Phase 1 clinical trial
and to ultimately be able to test it.
But in work that we've leveraged this, we've actually moved on from
the work, and this was actually presented in December by
Sanket Shah, who was a PhD
student and then postdoc, working with Ari and with me.
He actually presented this at the plenary session of ASH this December
and showed that not only
were the data that we originally found seen to
show African ancestry was more commonly associated with these DNA
damage sensing genes that we found in two additional cohorts,
including a cohort from Malawi, that that was also true in other
individuals of African ancestry.
And he's since gone on, I won't go through all of the data here, but to
describe that that's associated with a senescence-associated secretory
phenotype that we've defined by multiplex protein
imaging, by CODEX, and Lunaphor, and by
additional immunohistochemistry and flow cytometry.
And you can see that those individuals of African ancestry who were associated with
SETD2 more commonly have an exhausted
CD4 effector T-cell, a CD4 exhausted
T-cell subtype, as well as a CD8 T-cell exhausted
subtype. And that predisposes them to
a biology that may be targetable in other ways.
And so
Sanket has gone on to validate that in multiple different
ways. I won't go through all of these studies, but he's found that SAS signature
phenotype in mice across our SETD2 mouse model
and in human samples using RNA-seq proteomics,
phosphoproteomics, and flow cytometry, as I
mentioned.And so this new phenotype is one that we're starting
to leverage in ways to be able to understand how this biology might
differ for patients with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
And this is just one of a multitude of different approaches that we've taken
in a collaborative PO1 grant that Leandra Checchetti
and I run between Cordell and MD Anderson, looking
at projects in terms of the ways that epigenetics reprogram both the
lymphoma and the lymphoma microenvironment, and lead to
populations of patients that may be targetable in specific ways,
similar to what I just described for the SETD2
story.
The other thing that we've done through this, in work that's been led by Michael
Green, who leads our lymphoma group at MD
Anderson, is taking this to single-cell sequencing of
humans
samples where he's helped to define lymphoma microenvironment
archetypes or lymphomaps. And you can see here
that across data that I won't go through it in much detail, but
Michael has presented and published that there are three
major lymphoma archetypes, one that looks like normal lymph nodes that we call
the LN subtype, one that looks like fibroblasts and
macrophages, or we call the FMAC subtype, and one that looks like exhausted
T cells. And I think importantly, as we start to project these data
onto clinical trials, that's helping us to define how we might move
the path forward for patients.
And I think this is really instructive in terms of the ways that these
might provide value.
So some of you may be familiar with this large randomized controlled
trial that ultimately led to the approval of
axicell in the second line, where with the ZUMA 7 trial,
it took patients who had early relapse or refractory large B-cell
lymphoma and randomized them to either receive CAR T with
axicell or standard of care, which was additional chemotherapy and the
potential of stem cell transplantation.
And you could see that there was a large separation in the survival curves.
Well, importantly, when you project the lymphomaps onto that, we can now
define that there are patients with the lymph node architecture where there clearly
are marked differences here for patients-- Sorry, the colors are
flipped here, so axicell is shown in the blue and standard of care is shown
in the yellow. That there are clear benefits
to giving CAR T, both in that set, lesser benefits in the
group that had the FMAC subtype, and really no benefit in the group that
has the T-exhausted cell subtype.
We're now taking this approach and projecting it onto frontline
clinical trials, and you'll see data at ASCO
for some of those frontline clinical trials that I mentioned that will get
presented looking at this lymphomap subtyping and how that predicts for
outcomes in those settings.
I think Andrew Harpens, who I mentioned earlier, is presenting that as an oral
session at ASCO. The next phase of that really is taking that to
spatial, and I think one of the things that Michael has been
very innovative in doing is taking the ways that we define
subsets of
both lymphoma cells and normal tissue cells,
using single-cell transcriptomics and then projecting that
onto spatial transcriptomics. And this is something that's really
nicely leveraged the LEO cohort, where across the patients with diffuse
large B-cell lymphoma, where we enrolled more than 2,200 patients
with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma in the first five years.
We had 454 of those that we were able to put onto a
tissue microarray, and then to be able to leverage those
patient samples to be able to do techniques like whole exome sequencing, spatial
transcriptomics, and RNA-seq,
that presented some of the data that I
alluded to earlier. The other thing that's been very nice about
this opportunity is that we also are able to
see how the tissue samples that we have on TMA
relate to the overall patient population of patients with diffuse
large B-cell lymphoma. And so we can see whether there are systematic differences
in those group, and we really actually did not see any by major demographic
characteristics.
And so I won't go through any of these data, but this is just a
teaser to know that we have now completed the spatial transcriptomics on this.
And these will be getting presented at a meeting near you.
So what's next after this? Retirement.
You're probably thinking retirement for me.
But it's not retirement for me, it's retirement for CHOP.
So CHOP actually is now 50 years old.
CHOP was originally developed by
a group at
MD Anderson, including Eugene McKelvey.
Actually, Eugene McKelvey's daughter worked for me
a few years ago and has now moved on to another position at MD
Anderson. She may be approaching retirement soon.
And CHOP definitely needs to go there.
But this is 1970s chemotherapy, and we really need to try and move
beyond that to more innovative approaches.
Jason Weston at our place has developed this SMART START regimen,
where he took a regimen
where patients initially got rituximab, ibrutinib, and
lenalidomide as the first phase of this clinical trial with no
chemotherapy, and chemotherapy was not added until cycle number
three. This was published a few years ago in the "Journal of Clinical
Oncology" with quite favorable progression-free survival curves.
And when he first came out with this regimen, some people, including me,
thought it was dangerous not to give people chemotherapy who had diffuse large
B-cell lymphoma as an aggressive lymphoma.
And you can now see that that was not only safe to do, where only one
patient progressed on the RLI therapy, but that was a
therapy that was well-tolerated and had very favorable
outcomes.What he's done since then
is actually moved on to a new regimen called ULTRA, so using a combination
of rituximab, lenalidomide, acalabrutinib, and tafasitamab,
where patients get four cycles of therapy, and if they get a complete response in
the first cohort of patients, they only get two cycles of
therapy. And in patients in the second cohort, which we've now moved
on to and was presented at ASH this last year, patients get no
chemotherapy at all. And I won't go through all these data.
These have been presented previously.
But what you can see for this whole trial of 61 patients, that we could actually
take patients through a regimen without chemotherapy and have quite
favorable progression-free survival approaches.
And so we really need to rethink the ways that we're giving
approaches for patients in the future with more targeted therapies,
leveraging the molecular profiles, and more innovative strategies for
giving treatment. And so our
major future directions for our patients really are to start to
leverage these SMART therapies. This is the next generation of our SMART
trial, using gefitinib, polatuzumab, and gocatumab as
the upfront therapy.
And I won't go through any of the details here, but Dhai Jahar is leading this.
This will move from being an MD Anderson-only clinical trial to being
able to collaborate with outside institutions and are now looking for outside
institutions, including those that I showed you earlier, to be part of that
trial.
And so in conclusion, really, I think there are a number of opportunities
for reusing the molecular data that we have, both to derive
surrogate endpoints, but also to define subsets where we can start to leverage that
to drive new drug approvals, as I've shown.
And then to be able to define optimal therapies with biologically
defined scrub groups,
and then using those to develop chemotherapy-free regimens that are
emerging, and then hopefully through all that, to help
CHOP to finally retire early.
So with that, I'll thank you all for your attention and happy to take any
questions.
Hi there. Frank Slack from BIDMC. I'm not a
physician, but I am interested in CHOP and
retirement for it. I'm just wondering, in these SMART
regimens that you're proposing, what's the effect on just complete blood count?
Is it much safer?
These have been regimens in general that have been much more easily tolerated, and
there are selected patients where there actually have been some really
unusual responses, both from the first trial and the second
trial. There was actually a patient who got RLI in that first
trial, got two cycles of therapy, and said, "I'm not getting chemo," walked
away, and never came back.
And we call him every now and then. He's still alive, still doing well, still
doesn't have any evidence of lymphoma.
We also have some patients in that second cohort of study who
have gone all the way through the cohort.
They still are not at quite as long a follow-up that don't have any
evidence of disease. In both of those settings,
the toxicity of the regimen was markedly less in terms of the
cytopenias that we see with chemotherapy.
None of those patients had hair loss associated
with the regimen, and so they are less
toxic in many of the traditional ways that chemotherapy is administered.
Now, they're not non-toxic, though.
There are toxicities associated with these regimens, like rash and
other things that need to be managed, and you can get cytopenias with
lenalidomide given particularly
without attention to dose adjustment and those kinds of things.
And so they do need to be carefully addressed.
But with that, they've been much more tolerable than what we see with CHOP therapy.
And I think one of the things we take for granted is that CHOP, in general, as
chemotherapy goes, is reasonably well-tolerated.
But I've had even a handful of my patients who have documented their
course of CHOP therapy day by day, showing
how they lost their hair, how they lost their appetite, how they were nauseous.
And while it sounds reasonably tolerable for an
oncologist, it's pretty miserable for the patient.
And so I think we do need to think about ways that we can be able to modify this to
be able to improve outcomes for patients.
Hi, Chris. Thank you for the wonderful talk. I had a question.
Because there's so much heterogeneity that we're describing in these aggressive
lymphomas, do you have any suggestions on early clinical
signal? Because there's going to be such a multitude of different modalities being
tested, how do you generate the signal that actually gives you confidence to test
those in later lines to actually get to patients?
Yeah, that's a fantastic question.
And
my answer changed this week, I'll say.
It changed in response to some new data that are hot off the presses that I
mentioned from our spatial transcriptomics data, and changed in
ways that we need to think about at least
chemotherapy in the setting of diffuse large B-cell lymphoma and probably many
other diseases. You probably heard in the plenary talk, the
talk that Charles Shore's gave about plasticity across
prostate cancer.Well,
in our spatial transcriptomics data, we see tremendous plasticity across diffuse
large B-cell lymphoma. So while we describe it as the
ABC subtype or the GCB subtype, that doesn't really
seem to be true. In ABC DLBCLs, there are lots of GCB
cells that would mark phenotypically with a gene
expression profile and are malignant and look just like GCB
if you look at the single-cell level.
And inside GCB DLBCLs, there are cells that look like ABC.
And so it probably is not the traditional approach that we think
about trying to give synergistic chemotherapy
to kill the one lymphoma that is
there. But it's the variety of lymphomas that are there and coming
up with chemotherapy drugs,
where there are not resistance mechanisms to all of the drugs.
And there are some data on CHOP that suggests that that's the way that CHOP works,
that it's not actually synergistic, that it's killing off a variety of different
subclones, and there are subclones that are resistant to
cyclophosphamide, but fortunately, most of those subclones are not resistant to
vincristine or to adriamycin. And so I do think that
we need to leverage that biology to think about the early signals that
we're looking for. We can start to do that in some of the
molecular modeling studies that we're doing in PDX models and
elsewhere to know what are the early signals we can utilize.
Some of those will be approaches like cell-free DNA, where we've
commonly been using quantitative cell-free DNA
to
know how much lymphoma is there. But I think we need to move beyond that
and to use the molecular components of cell-free DNA to know which of the
components of the clones are actually there and coming back or not
coming back and being eradicated.
And so I think those are the tools that we ultimately will be able to use that will
help us to get readouts earlier and earlier in our clinical trials.
Great. Well, if there aren't any further questions, I think we're at our time, and
I appreciate everybody's time and attention and staying till late in the day
in this meeting. So thank you.